nbc chicago reports as chicago mayor
lori lightfoot approaches the two-year
anniversary of her inauguration reaching
the halfway point through her first term
she told the city's media outlets that
she would grant
one-on-one interviews to mark the
occasion but with one condition
she will only speak with journalists of
color
lightfoot tweeted wednesday morning i
ran to break up the status
i ran to break up the status quo that
was failing so many
that isn't just in city hall it's a
shame that in 2021 the city hall press
corps is overwhelmingly white
in a city where there where more than
half of the city identifies as black
latino
aapi or native american
what is aapi is that
pacific islander anyway i'm not going to
guess diversity and inclusion is
imperative across
all institutions including media in
order to progress we must change this is
exactly why i'm being intentional about
prioritizing media requests
from poc reporters on the occasion of
the two-year anniversary of my
inauguration as mayor of this great city
so you know first of all it's great that
this is her priority
as it's just bloodshed in the streets of
chicago
people kids women being shot and killed
as they walk down the street
um so that's happening you know morgue's
overflowing with bodies not because of
kovid but because of the violence and
the
you know the gang culture in the city
she's not worried
about that she's worried about making
sure there are more black people
reporters that
are that are at the press conferences
and and her response is and let's be
clear also
when she's saying oh i only want to have
interviews with
black latino aapi whatever that is or
native american what she's really saying
is
i don't want to be interviewed by any
white people
so sometimes they get away with this
kind of thing because they they sort of
try to frame it in a positive way
they say oh no we're just giving
opportunities to these uh to these
groups over here
but what you're really saying is you
don't want white people to interview you
because you only singled out one there's
only one group you left out you put
every other group in
it's kind of like when you are in third
grade and you invite everyone in the
class to your birthday party except for
one kid and of course
those of us with good parents we were
raised and told listen you can invite
the whole class
or you can invite one or two kids what
you can't do is invite most of the kids
except except one
that you can't do but uh
lori lightfoot we can assume for many
reasons was not was not raised well
um and so this is flat
out bigotry and racism against white
people it is
anti-white racism and that's what we
should name it
and call it that because that's what it
is now there may have been some rep i'm
sure if i checked there are some
republicans who
complain about lightfoot saying this
maybe tweeted about it i'm not sure i'll
assume that some republicans did
uh maybe even called it racism but there
was one elected representative on the
national stage only one that i'm aware
of
that went so far as to say this this is
tulsi gabbard who i should remind you is
not a republican she's a democrat and
this is what she tweeted
mayor lightfoot's blatant anti-white
racism
is abhorrence i call upon president
biden camilla harris and other leaders
of our country
of all races to join me in calling for
mayor lightfoot's resignation our
leaders must condemn
all racism including anti-white
calling calling it not just racism
anti-white racism and then saying that
lightfoot should resign
now i love this statement from tulsi
gabbard she's exactly 100 right
um what i don't love is that she's the
only one saying that and she's a
democrat
what what a shame what an absolute
shaming well-deserved shaming of the
republican party
that this is not coming from any
republican is coming from a democrat
and the thing is as a democrat saying
this you you know tulsi
this takes courage i actually have
respect she might be that she's the one
democrat one electoral democrat i can
think of
who i have respect for um even though i
still i still don't agree with many of
your views but
this actually takes courage
because all of your colleagues and
democrat party
your base you know everyone that you
that you need to support you and
everything
they're all going to be against you for
this because that's that's taboo you
don't talk about anti-white racism in
fact anytime
racism according to them doesn't exist
but republicans they would risk nothing
by calling it out
yeah the left's going to be mad at you
the democrats will be ready but they'll
be mad no matter what
um and most conservatives no matter
their race
black white doesn't matter are are would
be perfectly happy for you to call out
anti-white racism because that's what it
is
and it doesn't matter if you're a
republican who cares what the democrats
say they have no
it doesn't make a difference they're
going to hate you no matter what
you don't need them to like you and they
won't no matter what you say
so you have literally nothing to lose
you might as well speak up
but these cowards they can't even endure
they're going to get some frowny faces
in the halls of congress when they're
walking by the democrats
and they can't even that even that they
can't endure
tulsi gabbard put a lot more than that
on the line um
but we need to be very clear about this
as conservatives you know
uh if that is how you identify i think
we need to be very clear
it's not enough to just
blake it blanket statement condemn
racism
in response to something like this we
need to call it what it is it is
anti-white racism anti-white racism
exists there's a whole lot of it in fact
it's the only form of racism in america
that's socially acceptable
um and it's one of the only forms of
racism that's also institutional and
systemic
arguably another form of being
anti-asian bigotry which
through through affirmative action you
know that
is very real as well and systemic
um and yeah calling her for her to
resign the same way
i don't even i don't need to point this
out but i will
just if you can imagine a white mayor
saying that he only wants to be
interviewed by his fellow white people
he'd be a i think he'd be arrested i
think they would send the i think the
fbi would be knocking on his door and
they'd arrest him
for they'd find something
they they would arrest him for felony
rudeness
i guarantee it hate crime charges you
know you know i'm not
you know i'm right this is not i wish it
was like a joke or an exaggeration but
hyperbole it's not
they would call that a hate crime
[Music]
but lightfoot can say it and you know no
problem well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content